the jurogan experience what do you think
uh is gonna happen with trump what do
you know about the uh the raid the fbi
raid
i have no inside knowledge um
i don't know i mean
i think
i think he he did retweet us a couple
times um he retweeted me a couple times
too
hilarious
he uh
i was laughing my ass off i was like the
[ __ ] president retweeted me
i think that the people who are arguing
that that he's been given a ton of fuel
like they just poured rocket fuel in his
engine i think that's absolutely true i
mean if you just look at the fundraising
he's done off the back of this already
right but what did that absolutely yeah
but i don't mean in terms of politically
i mean like legally like what did they
find oh and zinnia actually is he
actually in trouble because i think the
goal is to try to knock him out of the
2024 elections right
now trying him for
crimes
what did he do
i don't know i don't know what he did
jamie did has it been absolutely
released what they caught i don't know
that yet but
holding on to
boxes is it really about he was like to
have confidential information that he
shouldn't have had in his home like that
was so important they couldn't just ask
for it they had to go in there and get
it well i think the par the problem is
having it right because if you have it
in an unsecured location meaning
unsecure in terms of the government's
protection it's not it's not locked up
in archives it's not in a place that's
very difficult to access you have
control personally over the access to
something that's top secret if that's
the case then that's a problem because
that safe could be open people can get
in there people can get the code they
can copy it they can send it to china
yeah but do you think that's a genuine
concern or is it they want to find
something anything that they can use to
prevent him from running again
um i think both things are valid
i think if they're just doing that and
they're using the fbi in a way that they
would never use it against hillary
clinton and they're going after him in a
way they would never go after galen
maxwell's client list oh my god then i
think there's no interest in that right
then we have a real conversation but it
doesn't mean that there shouldn't be
a real conversation about should someone
have access no i don't know what the
files were i have zero idea whether or
not
they were okay for him to have or
declassified i don't know but i but i
think the argument would be if you're
not supposed to if there's a [ __ ] a
whole chain of command about classified
documents and this this is the law on
classified documents and you decide to
violate that law because
you think you can right i just want to
keep them and you just keep them in your
safe i don't know if this that's what
happened but if that is what happened
that someone needs to be held
accountable for that you're not supposed
to do that right right you're not above
the law and you can't decide that you're
not going to follow the law because you
know better right and i don't know if i
think where people lose where they stop
where they don't care about that is
because they're like okay you know if
you're gonna be selectively enforcing
laws like that and just turn a blind eye
to hillary deleting emails that have
been subpoenaed
and all of that in all in
a blind eye to hunter biden trying to
act like this is not a story until
you're forced to admit that it is it's
the double standard that makes everybody
say this is persecution for sure and so
even if it's just even if there was
something that was done that was wrong
they're still choosing to be selective
about going after him in a way that
comes across as
they're after him doing what they
wouldn't normally do to someone on their
own side if it was hillary clinton's
home they'd have no interest in what's
in her safe because she'll kill them
yeah
jokes
um yeah i see what you're saying i see
both sides though i see you decide that
if you're an anti-trump person and you
find out that he's doing something
that's against the law you'd want him
prosecuted for it yeah i see both sides
yeah i really do um i don't know
the specifics of the hillary clinton
email thing in terms of like what those
files were but if they're the same
classification of files as like he had
you could make the argument they were
more vulnerable because they were on a
regular laptop well it's still destroyed
after a subpoena after a subpoena i mean
imagine imagine if trump was subpoenaed
for this information instead of handing
it over he burned it right that is where
[ __ ] gets really squirrely yeah gets
really squirrely and it's like what what
punishments are there for that is it
zero there's nothing nothing not a
[ __ ] thing right and everybody's just
like you know what didn't she have she
has a hat for sale it says but her
emails but her emails she's she's
capitalizing good for her yeah about her
emails i wonder if like amongst people
that are on the right now a
black hat with white letters will get
your ass kicked because
you're like the maga hat yeah like you
could have a maga hat that said anything
like i saw a lady get maced in the face
because she had a hat on that said it
was a red hat with white letters that
said uh make bitcoin great again and she
was at one of those protests there's a
video
yeah and some got some guy maced her in
the face
he pepper sprayed her in the face
because she had a red hat with white
letters about bitcoin that's assault by
the way it is assault well that happened
a lot at those
[ __ ] anti-trump protests that's it's
just
the problem is that he was such a
divisive character that he became a
great enemy for the other side he wasn't
like a statesman who like
you know you could criticize his
policies and his positions you could say
he's heartless all you want but he
represents the united states in a
statesmanly way and like no
trump's you know he's he's a wild guy
that like encourages people to hate him
do you think desantis would uh demand or
command more respect from the left
and the left still hates him but they
don't hate him the same way they hated
trump they try to but he's more
reasonable he's very like level in the
way he talks about things
he's firm though i mean yes he's yes but
you know what i'm saying like he's he
doesn't get he's not um
he's not an insulting
like uh
character like trump's a character right
like part of what he's doing he's like
doing comedy it's like he's doing
stand-up when he's up there i mean when
he makes fun of biden and makes fun of
other people like he's doing [ __ ]
stand-up he really is and he kills
it's he's got this thing you know and
that thing is like everybody's with him
is [ __ ] really with him and
everybody's against him is really really
against him and he like encourages it
you know he he that is what i think is
not good
that pro that part of it like you're i
get where he comes from because like
that's what made him fighting against
the haters you know but when you're a
president like that's a different role
that's a different role than being the
[ __ ] host of the apprentice right and
a lot of people hope that when he got in
there he was going to abandon that and
just be like common sense get [ __ ] done
but no he's on twitter calling his
ex-girlfriend horse face
saying about kim jong-un calling him
little rocket man he's [ __ ] what did
he said about rosie o'donnell oh yeah he
didn't call her fat pig something like
something like that i don't even
remember exactly what he said it was
nasty oh he says horrible [ __ ] he calls
her a loser all the time yeah but i mean
people think it's hysterical they do and
they do have something like but you know
the butt her emails thing but his mean
tweets you know like he could sell
shirts and stuff about that because it's
like you know yeah well yeah a lot of
people will say yeah he that i don't
approve of his tweets i don't like his
tweets no a lot of people would say that
yeah a lot of people a lot of people on
the right will say that yeah a lot of
people on the right this is where i
think they have hope in desantis that he
wouldn't do the same kind of things he
would never tweet things like that he
would never call kim jong-un little
rocket man all that [ __ ] was hilarious
it was funny he would never call his
ex-girlfriend horse face like that kind
of stuff is
you know in many people's eyes in a lot
of conservatives eyes it's unbecoming of
the commander
that's that's the argument against it